ach hoch seid ihr auch wieder da ich bin
halt auf dem weg briefwahlunterlagen
beantragen denn am 26.9 ist
bundestagswahl
[Musik]
ich bin absolut im wahlfieber zum ersten
mal seit 16 jahren wird angela merkel
nicht mehr bundeskanzlerin seien an alle
jungen die mitte der neunziger oder
später geboren wurden und es nicht
anders kennen es ist so dass bei
bundestagswahlen jemand anders gewählt
werden kann als angela merkel also
jemand anderes wird angela merkel sein
verrücktes ganz neues konzept nennt sich
die wahl haben lehnen wir in deutschland
aber eigentlich ab wenn wir jemand von
der cdu gefunden haben die kanzlerin
wird wählen wir die wie sie keine lust
mehr hat oder halt den ja auch männer
sind wirklich stelle nochmal kurz vor
wer das ist weil über ein drittel der 16
bis 19 jährigen die namen nicht kennen
diese drei menschen bewerben sich armin
laschet hat die superkraft angriffe
aushalten und dabei grinsen wie karlsson
vom dach olaf scholz hat die auszahlung
von einem taschenrechner nur mit dem
unterschied dass mit ihm wirklich
niemand rechnet seine superkraft extrem
schmunzeln als wüsste er etwas das wir
alle noch nicht wissen und annalena
baerbock superkraft
trampolinspringen tatsächlich sie war
trampolin springerin ist
trampolinspringen riechen job frage ich
mich da aber ich weiß beim thema ist es
wirklich im beruf sollte ich mich als
comedian nicht auf dem zu hoch setzen
egal ich habe auf jeden fall bock auf
die
wahlleute ich kann natürlich bekommen
wir kurz mal kart machen ich kann jetzt
nicht so tun als würde ich mich
ernsthaft auf die bundestagswahl freuen
das ist so als würde ich dieses alte
verrostete fahrrad als cabrio verkaufen
ich mach briefwahl damit ich es aus
langeweile nicht vergessen weil
überhaupt nicht über inhalte geredet
wird ich meine es gibt ein paar themen
die klimakrise wird immer mehr spürbar
bei der aktuellen unwetter katastrophe
starben mehr als 160 menschen etliche
regionen werden wochenlang kein
trinkwasser haben es gibt
milliardenschäden und die zunahme von
extremen wetterphänomenen ist genau das
was alle klima expertinnen und experten
vorhersagen und das was in deutschland
seit jahrzehnten passiert es geht so
viele unwetter in deutschland dass viele
bundesländer die katastrophen
soforthilfe gestrichen haben weil sie so
teuer wurde unter anderem nrw davor gab
es die zusicherung der länder dass sie
schnell helfen denn gerade dein haus
weggeschwommen ist aber die haben sich
dann gesagt wenn jetzt alle ihr haus
wegschwimmen lassen wollen können wir
den spaß nicht zahlen vielleicht können
wir dann doch noch mal darüber reden
welche partei etwas gegen die
klimakatastrophe unternehmen will
idealerweise bevor städte nur noch auf
dem wasserweg zu erreichen sind denn
niemand kann sagen dass die deutsche
regierung da genug getan hat das sagen
sondern angela merkel selbst und corona
hat besonders ärmere in deutschland
betroffen gleichzeitig ist die zahl der
millionäre in deutschland gestiegen auf
1,5 millionen menschen ich nehme an da
sind relativ wenige darunter die für uns
im kranken und pflegebereich am limit
gearbeitet haben falls sich gerade eine
ultra reiche krankenschwester nicht
gesehen fühlt gerne unter dieses video
kommentieren mit eure armut kotzt mich
an
gucken wir uns der erst die spd an die
hat tatsächlich einiges vor zentrale
themen sind 100000 sozialwohnung pro
jahr ein mindestlohn von 12 euro eine
vermögenssteuer für reiche die leute
freuen sich drauf und die abschaffung
von hartz 4 wenn man das hört denkt man
sofort aber warum habt ihr das nicht in
der regierung umgesetzt wegen der cdu
natürlich die spd kommt einfach selten
dazu die spd zu sein kann ich total ich
bin total friedliebend aber wenn ich
fünf stunden im stau auf der a1 stehe
muss ich alles regeln treten da komme
ich nicht dazu zu zeigen wie sehr ich in
mir ruhe in der cdu beschwert sich
niemand über die spd die sind richtig
zufrieden stimmung des wahlprogramms
läuft auch alles
klimakatastrophe ist auch ein großes
wort wenn man nach armin laschet geht
der sagte vor zwei jahren aus
irgendeinem grund ist das klimathema
plötzlich ein weltweites thema geworden
das ist so als würde heute ein virologe
sagen aus irgendeinem grund ist dass
viren thema plötzlich ein weltweites
thema geworden die cdu
hat eine ganz klare maßnahmen für den
klimaschutz die nahe liegt genau
autobahn bauen
weil es dann keine staus gibt das ist
eher der klimakiller nummer eins
das ist zu wenig autobahn gibt das denke
ich mir nicht aus das steht im cdu
wahlprogramm so drin ansonsten wenn man
auch was machen klar aber nicht so doll
also da will man niemanden belästigen
jetzt direkt will ich auch nicht
deswegen schnell und gut gelaunt zur fdp
erinnert ihr euch noch an den letzten
werbespot zur bundestagswahl habe ich
geliebt schwarz weiß christian im
unterhemd erzählt wie er die fdp aus dem
dreck gezogen hat gegen alle widerstände
die leute hassen dich die leute machen
witze über dich aber christian lindner
gibt nicht auf weil er ein traum hat
christian lindner bekommt beim reden
über christian lind nach komplett
gänsehaut für einen kurzen moment habe
ich mich von der stimmung des spots
tragen lassen gedacht ja christian ich
bin bei deiner mission dabei was machen
wir kommen wir werden straßenhunde aus
el salvador
ich will schoko boden schlecht für
bürgerämter christian nicht hält hier
nichts mehr ich habe meinen konnten
aufgelöst ich zieh mal eine
atmungsaktive kurze hose an in meinem
rucksack ist eine machete was ist der
plan
also du hast die fdp im bundestag zurück
gebracht bis jetzt steuern senken ok
cool
wer überhaupt richtig
ja hier bin ich richtig
[Musik]
bei der fdp muss man einmal sagen
wenigstens ehrlich die sagen frei heraus
wir sind dafür dass die die viel abend
noch mehr bekommen stumpf ist trumpf und
der markt entscheidet wo vizio zu
champagner dusche so viel offenheit ist
toll er kann sich niemand hinterher
beschweren wenn die soziale ungleichheit
zu nimmst du kannst nicht hannibal
lecter zum essen einladen und sich dann
wundern dass ihr nachname fehlt der
vergleich war ein bisschen schief klar
niemand sollte der fdp vorwerfen dass
die arme mag fdp ist der prosecco wenn
du sowieso schon alles hat der prosecco
soll nach deren willen übrigens
tatsächlich billiger werden weil die für
die abschaffung der schaumweinsteuer
sind wahrscheinlich die einzige position
die die fdp mit der linkspartei
gemeinsam hat
die linkspartei macht ihrem namen alle
ehre und hat super linke position die
abstrakter die aussichten der
linkspartei auf eine
regierungsbeteiligung desto konkreter
sind ihre forderungen und die forderung
der linkspartei sind sehr konkret es
soll ein mindesteinkommen von 1200 euro
für alle geben und sie sagen auch wer
das zahlen soll leute die mehr als zwei
millionen euro vermögen haben sollen
eine abgabe zahlen und leute die mehr
als 6500 euro brutto monat nicht
verdienen sollen mehr steuern zahlen
kohle ausstieg am besten sofort und um
so konkret zu sein muss man natürlich
dafür sorgen dass die chancen dass auch
umsetzen zu müssen sehr gering sind um
den job kümmert sich sahra wagenknecht
in denen sie ihrer partei vorwirft sich
zu sehr für minderheiten einzusetzen und
nur akademiker den städten anzusprechen
kann man sich nicht für minderheiten
einsetzen und für arbeitslose und prekär
beschäftigte dazu gibt es keinen
vorschlag und es wird weiter gestritten
das kann man den grünen nicht vorwerfen
die sind sich so einig wie lange nicht
mehr hauptthema natürlich umwelt bis
2030 will man den co2 ausstoß um 70
prozent reduzieren aber man merkt
niemand soll angst bekommen vor den
grünen nichts ist sehr konkret wenn im
konkreten zeitplan freilich for future
hat bereits kritisiert dass die
vorschläge der grünen nicht ausreichend
für das 1,5 grad ziehen sozialpolitisch
ist vieles ähnlich wie bei der spd ich
hoffe die setzen keinen plagiatsjäger
ins wahlprogramm also hab ich vergessen
die afg parteizentrale hört er nicht
sehen weil man sie offenbar nicht sehen
soll das logos mini klein auf dem
briefkasten die afg sich einfach selber
peinlich an alle mitglieder der afd das
ist nicht wie ein vertrag beim
fitnessstudio er könnte jederzeit
kündigen hier ist es wie immer die
ausländer sind an allem schuld nur nicht
am klimawandel da kann nämlich kein
mensch was für man kann die musik ohne
kugeln das ist quatsch ist aber wer
wählt wählt keinen pakt sondern das gute
gefühl dass man sich nicht verändern
muss sondern die anderen und wenn es um
wirtschaft geht wirkt alles wie schlecht
abgeschrieben bei der fdp lieber von
dateien klausuren wenn ich nur jedem
zweiten satz bei steffi entziffern
konnte so ist es auch bei der afg du
hast immer das gefühl die haben nur die
überschrift abgeschrieben und dann mit
dem pro visiert
de schreibt sie will zitat die umsetzung
wissenschaftlicher erkenntnisse in
produkte fördern sind die leute aus der
wissenschaft die erkenntnisse für
produkte liefern sind es die gleichen
die den klimawandel leugnen was andere
und wer will denn wissenschaftliche
erkenntnisse in produkten fördern als
gäbe es einen baustoff uns wer seine
angestellten leute wisst ihr was das
alles ja nie gelernt hat david physik
das machen wir heute mal nicht es ist
schon krass wenn man als partei nicht
mehr in der lage ist für fünf minuten
auch nur so zu tun als hätte man mehr im
programm als ausländer raus so ihr habt
die wahl ob ihr müsst jetzt nicht
begeistert sein bundestagswahlen sind
sowie ein buffet im all inclusive hotel
es gibt super viel auswahl aber nichts
schmeckt richtig gut aber wenn du nichts
ist wird das befehligt besser
irgendetwas was okay ist wirst du finden
die meisten jungen leute haben das
gefühl dass sich die politik nicht für
sie interessiert und ich glaube das
stimmt denn ihr seid einfach wenige es
gibt fast drei mal mehr leute über 60
als leute unter 30 und die älteren wird
die klimakrise nicht mehr so sehr
betreffen deswegen klingen viele klima
konzepte immer noch halbherzig am
meisten will fürs klima machen und die
linkspartei dann die grünen und dann die
spd und er immer schauen sagen cdu und
fdp und der afd ist alles egal aber dass
das klima für fast alle parteien so ein
thema ist ist freilich für filter zu
verdanken also den druck von jungen
leuten könnt ihr da bitte weitermachen
ich würde auf der nächsten demo dann
auch in prosecco stand klar machen
würde ganz im vertrauen ich brauche die
ganzen youtube es nicht aber meine
vorgesetzten hochfläche deswegen wäre
gut wenn du da abonniert geht auch ein
bisschen um die zukunft
also meine wer wirklich richtig danke